[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen an diesem
Freitagabend das wichtigste von der
nordischen Ski-WM von Sven Voss und
tollen Erfolgen der deutschen
Athletinnen und Athleten heute
klimastreik und Warnstreik in einem
Seite an Seite Verdi und Fridays for
future gehen gemeinsam für eine
sozialgerechte Verkehrswende auf die
Straße
Streit um Verbrenner aus ab 2035 die EU
hat ihre Abstimmung dazu verschoben auch
auf Druck der Bundesregierung
und erste WM-Medaille seit 12 Jahren die
deutschen Männer gewinnen in der
langlaufstaffel überraschen Bronze
[Musik]
vielleicht sind Sie ja selber davon
betroffen an vielen Orten fahren keine
Busse und keine Bahnen Bahnsteig im
Tarifkonflikt des öffentlichen Dienstes
will die Gewerkschaft Verdi den Druck
erhöhen die Forderung 10,5% mindestens
aber 500 Euro mehr im Monat
Unterstützung gibt es von Fridays for
future sie hatten für heute zum globalen
klimastreik aufgerufen
eine ungewöhnliche Liaison also auf den
Straßen die Klimabewegung und die
Gewerkschaft doch sie haben eine
Schnittmenge gefunden den öffentlichen
Nahverkehr falls for future sieht ihn
als wichtigen Baustein in der
Verkehrswende und wer die sagt dafür
brauche es gute Bezahlung der
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter Peter
Böhmer und Roman Lesko war berichten
ein Feuer zum Aufwärmen Minusgrade
nachts um drei in Leipzig der Nahverkehr
lahmgelegt Busse und Straßenbahnen
blieben im Depot
wir haben leider nur ein Stundenlohn von
ein bisschen was 13 Euro finde ich ein
bisschen arg wenig
in Wiesbaden Streikaktion am
Hauptbahnhof Busfahrer Thorsten Walter
sagt früher hätte ein Gehalt für die
ganze Familie gereicht heute ginge das
nicht mehr
Busfahrer ich habe ca 2500 € raus wenn
es gut läuft
ganz ehrlich schauen Sie mal alleine was
in der Miete hier in Wiesbaden kostet
also wir reden hier von der normalen
Dreizimmerwohnung da sind wir bei 1000 €
mit allen Nebenkosten und so weiter sind
sie bei 15 € daneben sie von 1000 € im
Monat
Kundgebungen und Demonstrationen heute
in sechs Bundesländern die Gewerkschaft
streikt wie hier in Köln parallel zu
vielen Aktionen in der klimaaktivisten
von Fridays for future und das bewusst
uns geht's natürlich erstmal in erster
Linie um die Verbesserung der Arbeits-
und einkommensbedingungen der
Beschäftigte im Nahverkehr aber das
steht und fällt natürlich auch mit dem
Thema Verkehrswende und da haben wir
gemeinsame Interessen mit den
Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten von Fridays
for future in manchen Städten wie in
Wiesbaden oder in Köln demonstrierten
verdi und die klimaaktivisten sogar
gemeinsam
[Musik]
Preis für future sieht dass die
Verkehrswende nur sozial gerecht
funktioniert und das bedeutet wir
brauchen nicht nur mehr Busse und Bahnen
sondern vor allem auch Menschen die die
Busse und Bahn fahren eine
demonstrierende Symbiose aus
Gewerkschaft und klimaaktivisten scharfe
Kritik dafür heute von den
Arbeitgeberverbänden politische Streik
sein in Deutschland verboten ein
politischer Streik der Gewerkschaften
mit dem Ziel z.B der Staat soll mehr für
den Klimaschutz tun wäre rechtswidrig
den Streik sind dafür da bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen oder mehr Geld
durchzusetzen ob die gemeinsame Aktion
heute den Arbeitskampf zu einem
illegalen politischen Streit machen das
mit dem Zweifel Gerichte entscheiden die
kommunalen Arbeitgeber als Tarifpartner
äußerten sich heute nur schriftlich und
nur zum lohnkonflikt die Streik aufrufe
sind in dieser Intensität
unverhältnismäßig und verbieten sich in
dieser Form vor dem bereits seit langer
Zeit feststehenden Verhandlungstermin
Ende März
die Fahrgäste nahm es heute gelassen
mehr Verständnis als Ärger ich habe den
Wecker früher gestellt
Termin also ich muss halt jetzt gucken
dass ich mit diesen überland Bussen
irgendwie hinkomme es geht schon
bisschen mehr Zeit einplanen passt schon
ja natürlich ist es findet mal findet
man das eben im ersten Mal im Moment
etwas blöd aber wenn man so die
Gesamtsituation zieht es sieht ist auch
irgendwo äh nachvollziehbar die
Warnstreiks werden an vielen Orten bis
morgen früh andauern
unser Klimapolitik haben wir auch ein
aktuelles ZDF Politbarometer und die
Zahlen hat uns Matthias Frauen auf
mitgebracht guten Abend Matthias hallo
guten Abend wir sehen dass die Befragten
tut die Regierung genug für den
Klimaschutz naja die meisten sehen auf
jeden Fall den großen Handlungsbedarf
und so finden 48 Prozent dass die
Bundesregierung zu wenig für den
Klimaschutz tut die Maßnahmen sind
gerade richtig so sagen 27 %. 19% finden
es wird zu viel getan mehr als zwei
Drittel der unter 30-Jährigen sagen es
passiert zu wenig aber nicht mal die
Hälfte der über 60-Jährigen
werden Demonstrationen und Proteste
etwas bewirken ja erwarten 24 Prozent
72% aber bezweifeln das ein weiteres
großes Thema ist die Menschen
beschäftigt ist der Ukraine Krieg was
sagt denn da die Umfrage welche Position
sollten die westlichen Staaten gegenüber
der Ukraine einnehmen da gibt es
geteilte Meinungen sehen wir gleich der
Westen sollte die Ukraine drängen für
einen Frieden auch Gebietsverluste in
Kauf zu nehmen das Sagen 41 Prozent
genauso viele aber finden der Westen
sollte die Ukraine dabei unterstützen
alle besetzten Gebiete zurückzuerobern
den Schulterschluss mit den USA in der
ukraine-krise finden 66 Prozent der
Befragten gut 28 Prozent nicht die engen
Zusammenarbeit mit den USA unterstützen
mit 71 Prozent im Westen deutlich mehr
Menschen als im Osten da sind es nur 46
Prozent Dankeschön Matthias
und das gesamte ZDF Politbarometer
können Sie heute Abend im heute schon
mal sehen ab 22 Uhr und natürlich schon
jetzt in der ZDF heute App
um den Ukraine Krieg geht es heute auch
beim Besuch von Kanzler Scholz bei
US-Präsident beiden in Washington Scholz
wird in knapp einer Stunde im Weißen
Haus erwartet zu einem
Vier-Augen-Gespräch ohne die sonst
übliche Pressekonferenz danach und für
uns in Washington Elmar warum so
vertrauliche Gespräche was wollen beiden
und Scholz genau bereden
also sie nennen es hier ein stilles
Arbeitstreffen und der Kanzler hat uns
das vorhin so erklärt die
transatlantischen Beziehungen sind sehr
gut aber damit sie sich weiterentwickeln
müsste man eben Vertrauen haben
zueinander und dem soll dieses Gespräch
dienen aus den beiden Umfeld hören wir
dass der Kanzler selbst um das Gespräch
gebeten hat um mehr über die
amerikanische Strategie zu erfahren
wohin die Reise eigentlich geht und das
betrifft zum einen natürlich vor allen
Dingen die Ukraine da hat es ja ein
jüngster Zeit tatsächlich Verstimmungen
gegeben hier in Washington hatte man das
Gefühl der Kanzler drängt zur Lieferung
von erems Panzern bevor er die Leo 2
Entscheidung fällen wollte und das
zweite Thema ist natürlich China er
beiden wird die Frage sicherlich stellen
ob man China mit Sanktionen überziehen
muss wenn es denn Waffen und Munition an
Russland liefern sollte die Antwort auf
diese Frage vom deutschen Kanzler werden
wir wahrscheinlich nicht erfahren weil
es eben ein stilles Arbeitstreffen ist
ohne Pressekonferenz danke schön MRT wir
sind über das Treffen von beiden
seit Monaten verteidigen ukrainische
Truppen die Stadt Mahmut gegen russische
Soldaten auf beiden Seiten womit
schweren Verlusten doch jetzt geben sich
die Angreifer siegesgewiss unter anderem
mit diesem Propaganda-Video das an einem
Vorort bachmuts aufgenommen sein soll
der Chef der Söldnertruppe Wagner
prigoshi spricht von der fast
vollständigen Einkesselung dann fordert
er Präsident selenski auf er solle den
letzten ukrainischen Verteidigern den
Abzug erlauben offiziell widerspricht
Kiew hat aber offenbar schon eine Brücke
in der Stadt springen lassen damit
russische Truppen schwerer nachrücken
können
und in der Ukraine ist für uns Hannah
Hebestreit Henna ziehen sich die
ukrainischen Truppen also bald aus
bachmut zurück
wenn du mich fragst ja die Frage ist nur
wann wir sind gestern an der Gegend
unterwegs gewesen da kam uns schon sehr
viel ukrainisches Militär entgegen die
fuhren aus der Richtung weg und dann gab
es heute morgen einen einen russischen
Raketenangriff auf eine Brücke im Westen
von bachmodi ist wichtig um die Stadt zu
versorgen dass Militär dort zu versorgen
hätte mich vor 3 Stunden gefragt hätte
ich gesagt okay das ist eine Sache von
Stunden dann müssen die da rausfallen
die Truppen einfach nicht mehr versorgen
kann wir haben jetzt aber Information
das militärreisen bekommen das Pioniere
diese Brücke wieder entstand gesetzt
haben und dass man weiterhin überzeugt
die Stadt halten zu können die Frage ist
wie lang der kommandierende des Osten
militärbezirks war heute in der Stadt
hat sich demonstrativ mit seinen
Soldaten gezeigt es ist den Leuten auch
gelungen ein russisches Kampfflugzeug
abzuschießen aus einem aus einem Bunker
in einem oder einer Stellung in einem
Hochhaus wir haben aber auch erfahren
dass Sie einige wichtige Truppenteile
abgezogen haben so die sehr bekannte
Aufklärungseinheit die mit Drohnen
operiert da hat man wohl große Angst
dass hier im Falle eines Falles von von
russischen Angreifern kampfunfähig
gemacht werden könnten die sind da weg
wie lange das noch dauert die Quelle
beim Militär meinte man wird das noch
versuchen so lange hinzuziehen
bis sich vielleicht auch die
Wetterbedingungen insgesamt ändern die
Felder sind matschig es ist alles ganz
schlammig der Schnee ist geschmolzen die
russische die ukrainische Schwarzerde
entpuppt sich zu einer Art
Klebstoff in dem alles stecken bleibt
was fährt nächste Woche soll es hier
schwere Regenfälle geben daran wird sich
soweit nichts ändern aber ich bin mir
sehr sicher es ist nur noch eine Frage
der Zeit bis bachmut tatsächlich
aufgegeben wird dankeschön
im vergangenen Jahr bekam aliaski den
Friedensnobelpreis weil er sich für die
Menschenrechte in seiner Heimat Belarus
eingesetzt hat heute hat ihn ein Gericht
in Minz zu zehn Jahren Haft verurteilt
angeblich soll er Proteste gegen die
Regierung finanziert haben weil jetzt
gehe hatte mit seiner
Bürgerrechtsorganisation
Demonstrierenden geholfen die
gegenpräsident Luca schenkow auf die
Straße gingen bereits seit 2021 saß im
Gefängnis den Nobelpreis bekam ein
Abwesenheit
nach Deutschland mehrere Jahre lang
wurden systematisch alle Fälle sexueller
Gewalt im katholischen Bistum Mainz seit
1945 untersucht heute wurde vorgestellt
was dabei herausgekommen ist es gibt
mindestens 4001 Betroffene 181
Beschuldigte und jahrzehntelang wurden
die Fälle sexueller Gewalt verharmlost
verschwiegen und nicht angemessen
verfolgt Christel Haas berichtet
der Blick auf den Mainzer Dom weckt bei
ihm schmerzhafte Erinnerungen an die
Zeit als er im domkor war und vom Kantor
sexuell missbraucht wurde er will anonym
bleiben mit Oralverkehr hat er sich bei
mir ständig vergnügt und hat seine
Sachen ausprobiert sprich er hat mit
massagegeräten an mir rumgemacht
Einfall von hunderten was im Namen der
Kirche seit 1945 im Bistum Mainz Kindern
Jugendlichen und Erwachsenen widerfahren
ist ist bedrückend und jetzt durch eine
Studie bestätigt Jahrzehnte lang hätten
die Verantwortlichen sexuelle Gewalt
vertuscht und das Leid der Opfer
ignoriert das bist du meins als
verantwortliche Institution hat durch
unangemessenen Umgang und Mangel die
Kontrolle in vielen Fällen sexuelle
Missbrauch begünstigt besonders schwere
Versäumnisse gab es vor aber auch
während der Amtszeit des populären
früheren bischofsmann es aber einen
erheblichen Gegensatz zwischen seinen
öffentlichen Auftritten und seinem
persönlichen Handeln gegeben das bist du
und der Missbrauch der jetzige Bischof
der steht ein das ist dem Kirche hat
versagt wir reden über ein Verbrechen
und nicht über einzelne Skandale
Menschen sind zerstört worden Glauben
und Vertrauen es ist mir als Bischof von
Mainz persönlich ein wichtiges Anliegen
meine Verantwortung wahrzunehmen und mit
den Menschen im Bistum die künftigen
Wege zu gestalten für den früheren
domchorsänger zählt jetzt nur eins das
was er erlebt hat dürfe sich nie mehr
wiederholen
erst Corona dann kauft Zurückhaltung
durch die hohe Inflation der Modehändler
Peek und Cloppenburg ist schwer
angeschlagen und suchte Rettung in einem
Schutzschirmverfahren das Düsseldorfer
Unternehmen mit rund 6.800 Beschäftigten
kann sich so in eigener Verantwortung
unter Aufsicht sanieren Filialen sollen
nicht geschlossen werden
ab 2035 sollen in der EU keine Autos mit
Verbrennermotor mehr zugelassen werden
das sollte nächste Woche beschlossen
werden aber jetzt wurde die Abstimmung
in Brüssel verschoben weil der deutsche
Verkehrsminister Wissing von der FDP
nicht zustimmen will er fordert das nach
2035 auch klimaneutrale synthetische
Kraftstoffe in verbrennermotoren
eingesetzt werden dürfen diese
sogenannten e-fuels werden jedoch
kritisch gesehen wie sie funktionieren
erklärt Volker Lucek
wenn es um den Verkehr der Zukunft geht
könnten neben Fahrzeugen mit Elektro
oder Wasserstoffantrieb auch sogenannte
e-fuels eine Rolle spielen
ifuels sind synthetische Kraftstoffe die
ohne Rohöl hergestellt werden aus
möglichst grünem Strom und Wasser wird
Wasserstoff gewonnen dazu gibt man CO2
aus der Umwelt und fertig ist ein
klimaneutraler
ersatz-fuels sind zur Zeit sehr teuer in
der Herstellung die Wirkungsverluste
sind sehr hoch
nach einer ADAC-Untersuchung kommen von
der eingesetzten Energie am Ende nur
rund 15% am Auto Rad an im E-Auto sind
es rund 75% der Ausgangs Energie heutige
Diesel und Benziner bringen 30% auf die
Straße doppelt so viel Energie wie
ifuels
experten halten die Nutzung von efuels
deswegen in Schiffen und Flugzeugen für
realistisch und sinnvoll denn hier ist
ein Antrieb über Batterie bisher
schwierig
im großen Maßstab für Autos das
erscheint vielen Fachleuten heute als
unrealistisch
in Brüssel wie kommt die Blockadehaltung
des deutschen Verkehrsministers bei den
anderen EU-Staaten an
es gibt zwar einige Trittbrettfahrer
anderer Automationen die ganz leise auch
dem Verbrenner noch mal das Leben
verlängern werden möchten aber
im Allgemeinen wird hier in Brüssel eher
mit dem Kopf geschüttelt die deutschen
Grünen im Europaparlament die sehen in
bissings Nachschlag ein absurdes
Schauspiel und die CDU im
Europaparlament die sagt in der Sache
mag er ja recht haben aber die Machart
das ist ein fataler Kollateralschaden
für Deutschland Glaubwürdigkeit hier in
Brüssel wenn man 18 Monate lang ja sagt
und nun am Ende nein die EU-Kommission
die gab sich hier heute mittag noch mal
gesprächsbereit sie sagte sie wolle sich
die neuen Bedenken des deutschen
Ministers noch mal anschauen wenn Sie
neu sagt dann sagt sie ja auch im Grunde
genommen dass diese Bedenken doch
reichlich spät geäußert würden und das
schwingt eben auch der Vorwurf mit dass
ihr ein deutscher Koalitionsstreit auf
der Brüsseler Bühne ausgetragen wird
danke
einig ist sich die Koalition bei diesem
Thema der Ausbau und neuererbarer
Energien müsse deutlich schneller gehen
eine entsprechendes Gesetz passierte
heute Bundestag und Bundesrat direkt
hintereinander es vereinfacht Planung
und Genehmigung von Windrädern
Solaranlagen oder Stromnetzen ist zum
Beispiel ein Gebiet bereits für den
Ausbau ausgewiesen müssen einzelne
Projekte dort nicht weiter geprüft
werden damit könnten ein bis zwei Jahre
pro Windpark gewonnen werden schätzt die
Regierung
Umweltschutzorganisationen sehen
unkalkulierbare Risiken für die Natur
Naturschutz heißt auch vielfältige
Lebensräume für Tiere und Pflanzen zu
erhalten heute am internationalen Tag
des Artenschutzes lohnt deshalb ein
Blick auf die deutschen Flüsse kaum
einer Volk noch wie hier seinem
ursprünglichen Verlauf Flüsse wurden
begradigt für die Schifffahrt und mehr
Nutzfläche für Landwirte gerade bei
kleineren Flüssen gibt es aber auf die
Chance zu renaturieren so und steht
neuer Lebensraum
Uferbereiche werden verbreitert um mehr
Überschwemmungsgebiete zu schaffen
zwei Drittel der weniger befahrenen
Flüsse eignen sich dafür ein Beispiel
die Havel Katrin Lindner berichtet
wer mit Rocco Buchta die Harfe entlang
fährt merkt was Liebe zur Natur bewirken
kann über 30 Jahre hat er für die
Renaturierung der Havel gekämpft damit
die hier lebenden stark gefährdeten oder
vom Aussterben bedrohten Tiere und
Pflanzen wieder eine Zukunft haben
angetrieben hat ihn ein Versprechen dass
er seinem Opa gab als eines Tages die
Bagger kam und die Steine an die Ufer
geschüttet haben um hier ein
transitschifffahrtsweg herzurichten da
war mein Opa so traurig er wollte nicht
mal mehr angeln gehen was er von
Kindheit antrat naja ich habe ihn damals
gesagt da war ich so 12 Jahre alt Opa
ich bringe das alles wieder in Ordnung
zu DDR-Zeiten wurden die Ufer der Harfe
begradigt und mit Steinen abgedeckt die
Bundesrepublik zahlte dafür denn sie
brauchte den Transportweg von Hamburg
nach Westberlin durch die DDR Rocco
wuchta und Verbündete Pflanzen schon so
DDR-Zeiten Bäume am Ufer gründeten nach
der Wende einen Förderverein 2010 folgte
der erste spartenstich für das derzeit
größte Fluss Renaturierungsprojekt
Europas auf 90 km wurden ufersteine
entfernt Altarme und fluterinnen
angeschlossen Auenwald gepflanzt noch
zehn Jahre soll es so weitergehen 70
Millionen Euro haben der Bund
Brandenburg Sachsen-Anhalt oder NABU
investiert
das wichtigste ist denke ich dass die
Arten die wir kannten das ist den
mittlerweile jetzt besser geht und das
war viele Jahre nicht so das ist erst
seit dem Projekt am Anfang hat so manche
über die Ziele gelacht jetzt aber steht
ihre Havel für etwas das auch woanders
Wirklichkeit werden könnte
jetzt haben wir zum Sport und ein
nordischen ski-wms wenn jetzt wird es
historisch absolut Jana denn das gab es
seit zwölf Jahren nicht mehr eine
WM-Medaille für einen deutschen
Langläufer seit heute hat diese
Durststrecke ein Ende mit einer
beeindruckenden Mannschaftsleistung
holte sich die deutsche langlaufstaffel
sensationell Bronze
es ist für alle vier die erste
WM-Medaille
stadtläufer Albert Kuchler hält das Team
im Rennen Janosch bruggerfeld 18
Sekunden zurück dann kann Jonas Dobler
die Lücke schließen bevor der Allgäuer
Friedrich moch den Zielsprint vor
Frankreich für Deutschland entscheidet
einen Tag nach dem Silber der
Frauenstaffel der nächste Langlauf Kuh
auf den Preis gefunden
vor Finnland für Deutschland ist es die
12 Medaille eine mehr als bei der bisher
erfolgreichsten WM vor sechs Jahren
stark erster Wettkampf nach der WM für
Weltmeisterin Denise Herrmann Wick beim
Sprint in novimiesto verpasste die
Weltcup führenden dieser Disziplin eine
Topplatzierung und wurde Sechste beste
deutsche war eine andere
gekämpft aber vorbei gelaufen am
Treppchenplatz Vanessa Vogt die erst
2021 im Weltcup debütierte glänzt mit
null Fehlern im liegend und stehen
schießen bedeutet Platz 5 ich freue mich
einfach allgemein
für heute knapp dahinter mit der
schnellsten Schlussrunde auf den 6 Platz
läuft Sprint Weltmeisterin Denise
Hermann Wick wichtige 40 Punkte für die
führende im gesamten Weltcup gewonnen
hat Norwegen Mate olds-land mit 0
Schießfehlern und der drittschnellsten
Laufzeit
die neue Formel 1-Saison startet in
Bachrain mit Rückkehrer nico hückenberg
hat nur noch ein deutscher Pilot einen
Stammplatz Mick Schumacher ist
Ersatzfahrer für eine Überraschung
sorgte heute ein alter Bekannter
Fernando Alonso lässt die Formel-1-Welt
aufhorchen denn zwischen 41 Jahre alte
zweimalige Weltmeister fährt Bestzeit in
Bachrain über die es gelingt dem Spanier
das im ersten Martin also im ehemaligen
Cockpit von Sebastian Vettel Weltmeister
Max Verstappen nach Radikalkur von 10
Kilo Winterspeck befreit bleibt hinter
Alonso auf Platz 2 Team Kollege Paris dr
schnellster ein Finger zeigt das Red
Bull auch diese Saison wieder um die WM
kämpfen wird Nico Hülkenberg einzig
verbliebener deutscher Stammfahrer fährt
im Hass die fünf schnellste Zeit des
Tages und überrascht damit ebenso am
Rande der arabischen Wüste
tja und die deutschen Skispringer haben
bei der WM in Planitzer eine Medaille
verpasst stattdessen hat gewonnen der
Slowene Timi Seitz also die Gastgeber
haben eine Goldmedaille ist doch auch
schön ja danke Sven das Wochenende wird
eher grau mit vielen Wolken ein wenig
Regen oder Schnee Regen ist auch dabei
genau das gleich von Katja Hornbach das
heute schon mal können Sie um 22 Uhr mit
Marietta Slomka sehen schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
guten Abend das ruhige März Wetter geht
jetzt zu Ende es gibt viele Wolken am
Wochenende und schon etwas Regen und
Schnee spannend wird es dann Anfang der
kommenden Woche wenn ein Tief über
Dänemark weiter ins Baltikum zieht sie
sehen an der weißen Farbe das ist da
durchaus für etliche Zentimeter
Neuschnee zumindest in den Bergen
reichen kann der Reihe nach heute Nacht
wird es noch mal kalt in der Mitte und
dem Süden da sinken die Werte auf -6 bis
-1 Grad im Norden bleibt es milder bei 5
bis 0 Grad da wären die Wolken die
bringen allerdings auch ein bisschen
Nieselregen oder schnee-riese mit
deswegen ist Glätte nicht völlig
ausgeschlossen im Süden ist es meist
klar da bildet sich auch mal Nebel und
morgen scheint dann hier vom Bayerischen
Wald bis zum Oberrhein häufig die Sonne
sonst wird das für uns eher ein drüber
Samstag mit etwas Regen etwas
Schneeregen freundlicher sie ist an der
Ostsee außen auch in Schleswig-Holstein
das liegt auch am Nord nordwestend wenn
es den ganzen Tag übertrübt bleibt dann
liegen die Höchsttemperatur nur so um
die Einrad mit Sonne am Oberrhein gibt's
dagegen 10 Grad am Sonntag kann es etwas
mehr Regen oder Schnee geben am Montag
gibt es kaum Sonne und am Dienstag
Wintergewitter im Norden guten Abend